and
[Music]
all the folklore of that Atlantic coast
of Colombia has always inspired you a
lot. Let's say that our roots
and the electronic music that we like a
lot too,
what we did was take those two
worlds and unite them and it's a stereo bomb
[Music]
hello us  We are Bomba Estereo, I am
Li Saumet and I am Simón Mejía.
50 years were invented, there
are centuries of music
[Music
] what happens is that from a rhythm
they should be a lot
up to cumbia bullerengue mapalé they are
corridos they are from blacks a
lot a lot to many cultures many
climates then many flavors many
ways of dancing
only important men  which is music
for dancing to start at
some time it has been very danceable again it
has been very spiritual right now it is
being very ecological but always
We are trying to make our message our
music fill
today. We are going to do a planting here
in Zinc Azsa, which is the main
water supplier in Bogotá.
I think this planting project began
as a process of being more connected
to the land and at that moment  and all
this year bomba stereo has been more
connected and more obviously talking
about environmental issues
we are seeing that there is a
huge crisis being at the level of deforestation in
the immense crises at the level of
plastic pollution in rivers and
in the seas it
affects us  that the world is
going through this and if we can
do something to help obviously we are
going to do it
and that is the patrimony is what we have to
take care of and take care of the future because the
future of the world is that the future of the
world is there
[  Music]